[Music]
stephen weinberg was a nobel laureate
statesman of science and voice of reason
he was universally regarded as one of
the greatest thinkers
of our age
[Music]
i first met stephen weinberg back in
about
1986 when i was a a graduate student at
harvard and was invited to give a talk
at the university
of texas austin where professor weinberg
was the head of the theoretical physics
group
now i almost never get
nervous before talks but this time
knowing that stephen weinberg would be
in the audience i was seriously nervous
i mean so much of my outlook on physics
had been
shaped by professor weinberg's writings
i mean when i was in
in high school i'd i read and re-read
his book the
first three minutes and in college his
textbook
gravitation and cosmology principles and
applications of the general theory of
relativity well
that textbook had been a kind of
companion to me i i
purchased it after a lecture by stephen
hawking got me
all fired up about space and time
cosmology relativity and all that and
and i i desperately wanted to understand
all the math
and all the ideas but back then i was
still a couple years away from having
the necessary
background so i simply carried
the textbook around with me everywhere
stephen weinberg was
always in my backpack and when
no one was around i'd sometimes take out
the text admire it's
it's rich blue cover sometimes running
my fingers over the title and
and when later on i finally was able to
dive in and
understand the material i felt like i'd
journey through the cosmos with the
rigorous but
crystal clear stephen weinberg as my
personal guide so
you can understand how going to texas to
give a talk and
meet weinberg in person was for me quite
the moment well the talk went off
without a hitch
but it was my conversation with stephen
weinberg
just after the talk which really stuck
with me
in my graduate student eagerness i had
thoroughly stuffed the talk with complex
equations
but with great tact after the talk
professor weinberg
gave me his own down-to-earth version of
many of the points that i had made
myself in the talk it was a
it's a virtuosic demonstration of
weinberg's
hallmark capacity to see through
complexity and reveal
the essence of ideas a capacity for
which stephen weinberg
was the unmatched master
with stephen weinberg's passing we have
lost not only a giant of science but an
extraordinarily erudite
thoughtful and sharp-witted observer of
the human condition
he was a great friend to the world
science festival
appearing many times in our programs
which allows us now
to hear from him in his own words
reflecting on
science life the state of the world
and where things are going from here
professor weinberg's own journey began
simply like many theoretical physicists
from an early age he could feel the
strange and wondrous
power of mathematics to illuminate
reality
i grew up in a modest family i was the
first to go to college
i found to my amazement teaching myself
some
physics and mathematics in high school
that you could do powerful things with
this intellectual apparatus i remember
calculating the shape of the cables that
hold up a
suspension bridge it's a catenary and
deriving the equation for a catenary
i thought uh wow you know i'm not
building a bridge but i can
see why it takes the shape it does and
uh that sense of the power of
mathematical reasoning
was intoxicating and of course
calculating the shape of a suspension
bridge cables was nothing new
and there was nothing i could publish
about it but um
uh i love the the intellectual power
and then eventually found i could
do something myself i it took me a long
time actually i wasn't at all precocious
in college the idea of doing anything
new
seemed infinitely difficult because
there was all that work
out there that had already been done and
i hadn't learned it all and i thought
you had to learn everything in order to
do anything new and then
uh when my wife and i got married we
decided
for purely romantic reasons to spend our
first year in europe and i
i went to the niels bohr institute at
copenhagen with a bag of books
that i was going to read again thinking
i wasn't going to do anything original
and they said well no everybody here is
doing research you've got to start doing
research
i said you're kidding i don't know how
to do anything new
and one of the professors there who
died recently gunnar chalain
actually suggested a research problem
and
i didn't know much about the subject but
by god i could do the problem and
didn't got a paper published and so
by the time i arrived back in graduate
school at princeton
i felt like a grown-up and
i'd made that transition from being a
student to being a grown-up
and um uh it was
it was really uh a difficult transition
which
you know it's like getting rid of your
skin like a snake getting rid of their
skin
uh but it's it's gone pretty well since
then
after making that difficult transition
from student to researcher
some scientists are content to drill
ever more deeply in the circumscribed
area in which they've gained
expertise stephen weinberg took a
completely
different tack drilling deep for sure
but
also constantly surveying the
intellectual landscape
observing and appreciating dependencies
and connections
that had escaped earlier generations of
thinkers
and among these was the recognition that
the arrows of explanation
point toward the most fundamental and
far-reaching principles of physics
being a profound relevance not just to
physics per se
but to our understanding of nature at
all
levels of explanation the world
is this is governed by a unified set of
laws which we don't yet know
but that physics and chemistry
are not separate sciences
and even biology is strongly influenced
as it is by historical accidents
like the shapes of the continents and
the fact that a
comet may have hit the earth 65 million
years ago
biology itself doesn't have independent
laws
there's no biological law that says
organisms have to evolve to get better
that's a consequence of
natural selection acting on inheritable
variations
which was really only on although it was
stated by darwin it was doubted
and it really only became well
established with the
neo-darwinian synthesis in the 20th
century
so i think that's a big thing you know
at the turn of the
20th century people were writing
articles about whether
physics is finished and i
i couldn't understand how anyone could
think that because
of course physicists had not succeeded
yet
in even beginning to explain chemical
laws
why uh sodium and chlorine
form a stable compound for instance
and so how could they think physics was
finished
and the answer was they didn't think
that chemistry was the job of physics
that was
something for the guy down the hall
and i the unity of science is something
we've
we've learned i guess you could say
we've unlearned the idea
that there are separate independent
principles
of physics of chemistry of biology
all standing at the same level of being
equally fundamental
with that unlearning of the natural but
naive supposition that all of the
sciences have an
equal claim of being fundamental finding
the laws that undergird
the most fundamental of sciences physics
that becomes all the more pressing
einstein himself
dreamed of encapsulating the laws of
physics in a
single coherent mathematical formulation
the so-called unified field theory
in its more modern formulation a unified
field theory would establish that
all of nature's forces are merely
different manifestations
of a single all-encompassing super force
famously after ardently pursuing this
goal for over 30 years
einstein came up empty-handed
taking a different approach stephen
weinberg was able to bring this dream of
a unified theory
one step closer he proposed
that two of nature's forces the
electromagnetic force which is
responsible for all
electric and magnetic phenomenon and the
weak
nuclear force responsible for
radioactive decay he proposed
that they are actually different facets
of a single force which is now called
the electro weak force
in the 1970s a series of experiments
confirmed weinberg's proposal leading to
his sharing
the 1979 nobel prize in physics
around that time john preskill who is
now
the richard feynman professor of
theoretical physics at cal
tech he was working on his dissertation
under stephen weinberg
and john joins us now from his home in
california
welcome john glad to be here brian
thank you you know um it's so nice of
you to join us for this
celebration of the the life and work of
stephen weinberg you
were one of his phd students
and i was actually your student back and
i think it was 1981 and classical
mechanics
class so in some poetic sense there's a
physics lineage between us all which is
a
a nice thing so thanks again for joining
us
how did you first meet stephen weinberg
well it was when i was a prospective
student i had just
applied to harvard i didn't know yet
whether i was going to get in
and my then fiance now my wife roberta
and i were in boston
for the day just for fun and we thought
on kind of a whim well let's go to
harvard and look around there let's find
out what the physics department looks
like
and it just happened that steve weinberg
was in his office
and you know i'm usually a pretty shy
guy and so it seems a little amazing to
me now because you know i've met with
many prospective students
over the years at caltech and i can't
remember any one of them ever coming to
see me with his fiancee but that's what
i did
i came in i said steve this is um i said
professor weinberg
this is um my fiance roberta and i'm
interested in
getting a phd at harvard and i'd just
like to hear a little bit about
your research and he didn't act like
there was anything unusual about that in
fact he said oh
louise and i did the same thing he and
his
uh later wife and fiancee had also
looked around at graduate schools
together so it seemed very natural to
him and we had a very friendly chat
and obviously you were convinced that
this is the place that
you wanted to go and and is is it i
heard that
that that professor weinberg actually
met with your parents
at some point well that was later
uh around the time that you were taking
my class i think probably around
1981 i was a faculty member at caltech
then an assistant professor
and my parents were visiting us and um
i knew they'd really enjoy meeting steve
so we had him over for dinner it was the
summer time we had a pool in our
backyard we all went for a swim i
grilled chicken we ate dinner outside
and steve i think realized that
i was kind of trying to impress my
parents you know that i was
a colleague of the great man and he
played that that role superbly
and treated me with uh you know
considerable deference uh
beyond what i deserved but the most
memorable thing about that evening for
me
is at one point for some reason we were
talking about how you make ice cream
and steve said you know i always
wondered why are you supposed to put
salt in the ice cream maker
and my dad said well isn't it so it'll
lower the melting point of the ice so
the ice cream will get colder and
solidify and steve said of course that's
it
thank you and uh he may have played that
up a little too but
for my dad it was fantastic because he
could gloat for
the rest of his life for the next 20
years about how he had taught science to
stephen weinberg
and and and was that how stephen
weinberg
was i mean was he generous in terms of
spreading around you know credit for
ideas and
making people feel good about the
process of research and discovery
well i wouldn't say that was uh you know
the first uh character trait you would
associate with him
you know as a scientist he was very
solitary unusually so
he was not so much of a collaborator in
fact this morning
i was kind of browsing through some of
his best-known papers
and i looked at like the top 50 or so in
citations you know 42 of those are
single author papers
he just didn't collaborate very much it
wasn't natural for him he'd like to
think things through
for himself and of course he was he did
give credit you know he was very
meticulous
about citing people and also
he was a little bit uh sensitive if
he didn't get cited when he thought um
he deserved it and so
you know he appreciated that other
people would
expect the same treatment and so he was
very careful about that to give credit
when it was deserved
now one of those solitary papers was uh
the 1967
paper in which you put forward
ultimately the work
that he would receive the nobel prize
for but
by the time you were his student
that work was kind of old i mean it
wasn't
it wasn't passe but it had been around
for a while was he still
thinking about electroweak ideas in the
mid 70s or
did he do that work and just sort of let
it go and just would see what would
happen
well he was sort of on to the next thing
um he
uh was interested in grand unification
for example you know the next step in
unification
and he was interested you know in those
days we were hoping people would detect
proton decay maybe they still will which
would give us some insight into particle
physics at very
short distances he was interested in
that he was interested in what we now
and i guess even back then call beyond
the standard model physics
you know what what else is there that we
might discover
in the next generation of accelerators
of course
in those days you know we were thinking
ahead to uh
to the ssc which sadly was was never
built
um but uh that all those things
influenced me
you know we it was steve's
style with respect to how he
interacted with students was similar to
his style when it came to interactions
with other scientists
not so much of a collaborator and
he inspired me in many ways when i was a
student but a lot of it was from
reading his papers and trying to absorb
and digest his ideas
rather than in you know one-on-one
contact when we did
talk he was often pumping me for
information steve always was trying to
learn something new
and if there was some topic that that i
had studied in more detail than he had
our conversations would be
focused on him trying to find out for me
what i knew that could help him he was
almost like that interacting with other
scientists you know he wanted to find
out
what somebody knew that was relevant and
helpful for his own work
yeah everyone's had a long conversation
about deformations of complex structures
of columbia manifolds and
you know he by the end of that
conversation with me i think knew more
about the subject
than i did and i'd sort of been working
on it for years
but after the 1967 paper it wasn't like
he put out this paper
and the world of physics just said yes
this is the answer it took a number of
years
before people really took notice of
these ideas
and as experiments in the 70s began to
make it clear
that electroweak unification was
right no doubt there was a sense that
this was nobel
worthy work so was there a kind of sense
around harvard in the uh the october
fall period of each year
a kind of tension waiting to see if this
might be the year
when the nobel prize went to stephen
weinberg by the late 70s that was the
case yeah
it was just as you described you know it
for about four years after that 1967
paper the ideas really didn't catch on
very much you can see that in the
citation record
not many people were following up on it
it changed rather abruptly in 1971
uh in particular because of work by
adwords and development and others that
sort of made it clear that the
theory really did make sense uh
mathematically
and then interesting it really started
to skyrocket and then by
uh by 1973 experimental evidence was
starting to pour in uh supporting the
predictions of the model
but there was still controversy for a
while in the mid 70s you know is that
really the right model how well do we
know that how
convincing are the experiments pretty
well settled though by 1978
in particular by experiments in slack in
which they saw that
left-handed and right-handed electrons
interact with nuclei differently as the
theory predicted
so by the late 70s every october yeah
there was
kind of some anticipation maybe this is
the year because it seemed like this was
clearly a nobel worthy
discovery and adding to the drama
was that uh steve and
shelly glashau who were both harvard
faculty members with
offices on the same corridor were both
nobel prize candidates so of course the
nightmare
scenario was that one of them would get
the nobel prize and not the other but
luckily that did not happen and in 1979
when they shared the prize with abdus
salaam
that was an exciting moment and so what
what
were you there i mean when steve found
out
i mean did wha what i mean it's just
like champagne and excitement i mean how
did steve respond to this
this accolade he he was nonchalant
you know i'm deep no with his
sense of the history of physics i think
he very much appreciated
the significance of receiving this honor
who wouldn't
but he acted he kind of brushed it off
you know
he was teaching a class and he had
prepared the class the night before you
know how it is you get the call in the
middle of the night
if you know you're in the u.s or very
early morning
and then you're not going to go back to
sleep and it's all very exciting
but he had been up the night before
preparing his class so he was going to
teach that class come what may and he
did
he went ahead with the class he said
i've prepared this class i'm certainly
you know not going to
waste all that preparation time and not
teach it and he did but of course he was
very
uh very proud to receive that
recognition
just to get a sense i mean where would
you place electroweak unification in
sort of the pantheon of great
physics breakthroughs is it is it up
there
with you know einstein's insights i mean
where where would you
place it well that's a pretty high
standard
isn't it yeah but i would certainly say
in the historical
sweep of physics it was a major
milestone you know
in physics there has been a steady
march towards a more unified and
complete
understanding and description of how
nature works
and so you know there were uh
events like uh recognizing that the
terrestrial
and the celestial could be combined in a
universal theory of gravitation that was
newton
and maxwell realized that electricity
and magnetism
fit together in a way you know they
couldn't really be separated
and einstein realized how to get
special relativity to fit together with
the theory of gravitation
a great step forward as well
and this was a significant step in
in that progress because now we had a
unified way of describing
two of the forces electromagnetism and
the weak nuclear force that's what
steve's model uh was all about and also
the contributions of glacier
and salaam and others and you know it's
if you look back over what's happened
since
in fundamental particle physics there
has not been any
comparable advance i think since then
and so
would you say that there was a
particular approach
to physics or or a style of thinking
about these problems that
is responsible for propelling weinberg
to
have made this advance where nobody else
had really
for a long time before or a long time
since
well i'll tell you that's i find that a
hard question to answer and here's why
steve was not a model builder that
wasn't his style
his style was to be very methodical and
general and he was
masterful at that he would try to you
know
figure out what the ground truths were
on which you could build
a deeper knowledge and many of his
papers are like that
very general arguments starting from
first principles
he didn't like building models himself
he appreciated when other people did it
because he
figured well a model is just a model and
it's not going to really be right
you know it's not going to be the right
answer to how nature really behaves it
might teach you something
he would rather give a more general
argument that would apply to
models that people might dream up in the
future
this paper wasn't like that it was a
model
and uh i think another thing that was a
little uncharacteristic
was steve was not so much the type of
scientist to have an
aha moment you know a flash of insight
and suddenly i
i see the answer he was more like i said
he had a methodical style
and but this was a flash of insight he
was working on a somewhat different
problem
trying to understand properties of the
strong interactions and he suddenly
realized
that wasn't working but the same
concepts could be applied to a different
problem which was this unification
of uh electromagnetism and the weak
nuclear force
so it was very uncharacteristic of his
career really that he had
that flash of insight of course it as
was
uh more typical of him you know that
built
on some years of thinking and experience
with the types of we call them gage
theories that eventually turned out to
provide the answer
you know around that time it it
he must have been working in parallel on
his first popularization of physics like
the first three minutes
were you aware that he was writing a
popular book i mean was he writing that
book when you were his student
he was and in fact the story of the book
is
that he gave a public lecture this was a
little before your time at harvard i
guess
uh but uh it would you know it was in
the science center
uh you know full completely full uh
audience
and uh he talked about the early history
of the universe in that public lecture
and he made a joke in that talk
he said you know and then after the
first three minutes
when the uh you know the helium
had formed in the universe not much
happened after that you know
uh it was the story was kind of over
after the first three minutes
and uh it turned out that a uh
a publisher you know heard from a friend
about that joke
and thought boy this could make a very
interesting book so steve wound up
getting
contacted and asked whether he was
interested in writing a book
and he decided he was you know he had
written
a textbook on
gravitation and cosmology and that's a
little
unusual because he was not that wasn't
his
area of science right he was a particle
physicist
and it's there's something pretty
interesting about that book which
we haven't really talked about this yet
but about steve's style
he was a very non-visual thinker you
know
and in particularly you know well
brian in general relativity it's a it's
a rather visual
subject it's about geometry people draw
diagrams you know if you're
stephen hawking or roger penrose you you
think
visually about those things steve did
not think that way and it's quite
striking to look at his book on
gravitation there are no pictures
yeah he didn't like pictures um in fact
here's
he um another funny thing
is when he got his first pc you know
some of your
viewers may not know but there was no
windows then it used to
to run on another operating system
called das ms-dos you just type into the
command line
and when windows came out steve didn't
like windows he didn't like icons he
wanted to just type on the command line
you know
he just didn't think in terms of visual
things he thought
that people put too many gratuitous
pictures in their um
in their papers why do you need the
picture it's all in the equations
well i i think and maybe in some
editions of his textbook there's a
footnote a famous footnote where he says
any similarity
to the differential geometry that had
been developed
that einstein made use of which is a
very visual subject
that was just sort of a coincidence it
wasn't the heart of the
general theory of relativity and i don't
know if he ever changed his
mind on that perspective i'm not sure
but of course you know you and i know
that's not the whole truth
right and at this around the same time
another great book on relativity came
out by mr thorne and wheeler and it was
full of pictures because
john wheeler was a very visual thinker
and fine anyway
yeah i mean it was a very it would turn
out to be a very influential book the
first three years
and it was um intended
for a lay audience but it's pretty
technical book i think it's pretty hard
going for people who don't have
scientific training
but it was read by and i think had an
influence on a lot of scientists
yeah certainly on on me for sure um
was there any pushback in that era of
someone taking time out of research to
write a general book for the general
public
i don't think there was really pushback
i do remember one incident
where uh this doesn't really qualify as
pushback but you kind of brought it to
mind
leon letterman came to harvard and gave
a talk the physics colloquium
and he started out with a joke he said
that
he had heard that steve had written a
book and so he went to a bookstore
to look for it and he said do you have
the book
the first three minutes and whoever was
helping him in the bookstore said
yes we do and we're selling a lot of
them and
letterman said well isn't that kind of
strange that a book about science would
be selling so well
and the reply was science i assumed it
was a sex book
yeah and uh so letterman thought that
was a pretty good joke
yeah i think let's make that um
known letterman yeah um so
when one thinks about the the remarkable
life
of stephen weinberg and as students are
going to continue to read
his many textbooks gravitation and
cosmology was just one of them as
students continue to learn about the
election week unification and all the
other
contributions that stephen weinberg had
such a vital role in
is there something that students
you feel should take away from his
approach to physics
that can help guide their own trajectory
guide their own
course through research well i'm sure
there are many things of course
you know we're all different and
different scientists succeed in
different ways so what would work for
stephen weinberg might not be the best
method for somebody else but he was
very successful at identifying the right
problems this is the key
in many cases to making scientific
progress and
the right problem should be one where
you have a good chance of making
progress
even if you can't solve it completely
but um where it'll really have some
impact and advance our understanding in
a significant way
if you do make that progress and steve
did that again and again so i think
it is important for students to be very
thoughtful about the things that they
work on and to keep those criteria in
mind
that you want it to be something you can
really do and of course different people
have different strengths and weaknesses
so that's kind of a personal
decision about where you think you can
push progress forward but also
if you succeed how will it give us a
deeper understanding of
science at some fundamental level that
was one of his strengths
and we haven't really emphasized except
uh
for the first three minutes how
particularly in his later career he was
a marvelously effective
scientific communicator uh
the essays he would write for the new
york review of books
how many of which were collected in in
books
that he published can be
guaranteed to provide
interesting insights any subject that he
that caught his interests
he could write about with exceptional
clarity
and with a real intellectual honesty you
know he would tell you exactly what
he thought and he would explain why and
he did that with great respect for the
reader i think this was an important
thing to realize about steve as a
communicator
he appreciated that there are people who
are not scientifically
trained but are just as smart as brian
greene or
john prescott you know or people who do
have some training in theoretical
physics he didn't talk down to them
but of course he realized that you
couldn't talk to them in jargon
and so he he had a very uh
strong gift for um
communicating things through clear
language and good examples and analogies
yeah he was certainly a a spectacular
writer thinker so much insight in his
essays and articles and of course you
know one of the great scientists
of our age so thank you john so much for
your insights
into stephen weinberg we appreciate it
greatly
all right it was a lot of fun brian
with all the advances in understanding
the basic laws and properties of nature
that understanding nevertheless had
significant limitations
and no one was more aware of that than
stephen weinberg
we have a very good theory of all the
particles and forces
that we can study in the laboratory
which i gave the name the standard model
um which seemed to me
not excessively immodest i mean
biologists have something called the
central dogma but
uh it works and in an almost
boringly repetitive way we keep testing
it
the discovery of the higgs boson a few
years ago
turned out to just fit what was expected
the standard model predicts all of its
properties except its mass
and it was found with all those
properties
and now we know the mass experimentally
it would be tragic if the only thing we
did
at the large hadron collider or anywhere
else was to go on
elaborating the verification of the
standard model
and because the standard model certainly
not the end of the story
no one thinks it is it has a lot of
unexplained
features like numerical quantities
ratios of masses
we don't know where they come from it
doesn't include gravitation
which is a big thing not to include um
and we uh we're not
we're happy with it as far as it goes we
desperately want to go beyond it
and uh we may not be able to in our
lifetimes
in that remark weinberg captures really
well the
the kind of mixed feelings that many
physicists have regarding the standard
model
it is undeniably utterly remarkable that
with a mere handful of mathematical
equations
the equations of the standard model
physicists can explain
every piece of data collected at every
particle accelerator in the world as
well as data from cosmic rays and a
great many other astronomical
observations
all the same the standard model is based
on a number of
key assumptions that so far scientists
have
been unable to explain from some kind of
deeper
understanding in the standard model
there is a somewhat mysterious list of
particles that appear in this theory as
elementary particles
among them are quarks two kinds of
quarks the lightest ones
make up the protons and neutrons which
in turn make up atomic nuclei
three quarks in each proton or each
neutron
but there are altogether six types of
quarks
the other four are heavy and unstable
they're all equally important as far as
the standard model is concerned
it's just an accident the two of them
are the ones that appear
in ordinary matter there are other
particles there's the electron
and it has a couple of siblings which
are just like the electron
but heavier and also unstable now we
have a table
based on experimental data of the
properties of these particles
their masses especially and
we know what their masses are but we
don't know why they are
we've been looking at this table of
experimental information
about these masses now for several
decades
with the feeling that it's got to be
telling us something
and we don't know what it's telling us
it's a little bit like
having a manuscript in a say linear a
a language that hasn't been deciphered
you feel you ought to know what it's
saying but you don't know what it's
saying
what's more even with weinberg's
synthesis of electromagnetism and the
weak nuclear force and
even with the standard model's capacity
to explain the behavior of familiar
matter
if not its intrinsic properties
observations and data establish that the
standard model is
demonstrably incomplete as a description
of nature
a realization that has driven much of
physics over the course
of the past few decades another thing
astronomers tell us that 5 6
of the matter of the universe
is some kind of dark matter which was
discussed already in a panel in this
festival
this dark matter none of the particles
of the standard model
have the right properties to make up the
dark matter
so 5 6 of the mass of the universe is
not in the form of anything described
by the standard model well something we
ought to
know more about and finally there's a
little technical detail
that gravity doesn't fit in the standard
model it's also something we would like
to know
more about so we have to
hope for more insight from the next
generation of experiments
at big accelerators like the one
that i mentioned before at the large
hadron collider
in europe now that is pretty big it's 17
miles in circumference
it's not visible from space because it's
buried in a tunnel
which goes across the border between
france and switzerland
in this accelerator two beams of protons
are going
round and round kept in their orbits by
powerful magnets
the magnets have a strength oh roughly
10 000 times the strength of the earth's
magnetic field
which acts on compass needles
when the large hadron collider gets up
to its final
design capability it will accelerate
particles to an energy which is about
7 000 times the energy contained in the
mass
of a hydrogen atom it's an energy which
is about a million times the energy
of the alpha particles in rutherford's
famous
experiment it is certainly big science
it's also big science in another sense
a human sense which is not so good
the exp one experimental team at the
large hadron collider
that i happen to look up for this talk
the atlas collaboration
has over a thousand phd physicists
working together they'll all sign the
research articles when they come out
the title page will be much larger than
the rest of the article
and uh the i don't know
how a young experimental physicist
can make a name for himself or herself
working in a collaboration like this
also the experiments from planning to
completion
take over a decade which is a fair
fraction
of a scientist's working career and
it may be an experiment which turns out
to yield nothing
exciting so
i just thank heavens every day that i'm
a theorist
i don't have to do that um
but we're forced into the mold of big
science by the logic
of the subject at any one moment
the particles that we know about are
those
that have a low enough mass so that they
can be created at existing accelerators
and if you want to find new forms of
matter
to fill out our picture of the way the
world is governed
then you have to have higher energy and
we can't help it
the purpose is not to get records for
the number of particles or the energy
it's to learn about the laws of nature
weinberg's point is that physicists seek
out new particles
not to add to some kind of taxonomy of
ingredients
but rather to glimpse the foundational
laws
and principles of which the list of
particles is a prime manifestation
that is the knowledge of particles and
the understanding of their properties
and interactions
is the sharpest means that we have for
deducing
the fundamental laws there's one
particle in particular
that we expect without certainty to be
produced at the large hadron collider
it's a particle called the higgs boson
it is predicted as a necessary
feature of nature by a theory that
unifies the weak and electromagnetic
forces that brian mentioned in his
kind introduction
in this theory i should explain the weak
nuclear forces are forces
that act inside the atomic nucleus
allowing neutrons to turn into protons
or protons to turn into neutrons um
they're very short range and hence they
only act inside
the nucleus the electromagnetic forces
you all know about that light that's
staring me in the eyes is uh an
electromagnetic wave
and we've all felt the force of magnets
pulling on a piece of iron
they seem very different but in the
equations of the theory they are treated
the same way
also in the equations of the standard
model
these the particles the that i mentioned
earlier the quarks and the electrons and
so on
have zero mass yet obviously that's not
the way nature is what you have is a
situation
where you have equations with certain
very great
simplicity a great degree of symmetry a
symmetry between the weak and
electromagnetic forces for instance
a simplicity that says all the masses
are zero
and yet that's not realized in the
solutions of the equations
which describe what actually we see in
nature
how does the solutions not respect the
symmetry of the equations well
their various ideas the simplest idea
which appeared in the original version
of this theory
invokes a new set of fields in addition
to the electromagnetic field and all the
other fields of the standard model a new
set of fields
which pervade the universe one of which
is
would be manifested as an actual
physical particle
electrically neutral heavy unstable
which has come to be called the higgs
boson
and this particle if it exists
will be found at the large hadron
collider
because we know enough about it to know
that it's if properties make it findable
well the large hadron collider
did indeed settle this question by
finding the higgs boson
the elusive particle whose corresponding
feel pervades the universe and
like a cosmic bath of molasses exerts a
drag force on other particles that
appears to us
as the particle's mass the confirmation
of the higgs particle
concluded the experimental verification
of the standard model
of particle physics for which stephen
weinberg was a prime architect
nevertheless the deficiencies of the
standard model to this
day still remain no one knows why
particles like electrons or quarks have
this or that mass or electric
charge no one knows how to incorporate
dark matter into some kind of
extension or revision of the standard
model
no one knows how to incorporate gravity
into our fundamental description
of nature's elementary particles but
these
questions of the small and the ultra
small
are not the only ones that fascinated
steven weinberg
gravity in the cosmos inspired an
equally passionate urge
to understand you know
we talk endlessly about black holes but
we don't see black holes all we see is
the
accretion disks around black holes and
we become convinced that there are black
holes in there but we don't we can't do
experiments
or direct observations on black holes
the whole thing is just
terribly frustrating and
for the time being i'm much more excited
by the experiments that
we were hearing about from ligo and
hoping
advanced ligo goes on the air soon and
discovers coalescing neutron stars
something we get our teeth into
indeed just as steven weinberg
anticipated
ligo the laser interferometer
gravitational wave observatory
has now seen coalescing neutron stars
as well as colliding black holes leading
the way to a
new era of observational astronomy that
promises
unparalleled insight into the cosmos
but as weinberg also noted even with
such insight
it seems likely that some of the deepest
questions will be with us
for generations to come well the
question i'd like to answer
i don't think will be answered in our
lifetime
even your lifetimes let alone mine uh
is um what are the laws of nature
and but more specifically are we getting
a good sample of the laws
of nature as really fundamental or is
the big bang that we see
just one tiny part of a much larger
universe
in what in which what we call the laws
of nature vary from one part to another
i'd like to know the answer to that and
i hope the answer is
uh that this idea that
the universe is much bigger than just
what we see called the multiverse idea
is wrong because then
although there are suggestions that
it might be right but it would mean that
we can calculate
much less just as kepler was wrong in
thinking that we can calculate the
distances
of the planets from the sun from first
principles
we may discover that a lot of the things
that we think we can calculate from
first principles
are just environmental parameters that
would be very sad but it may be true
weinberg was not only a towering
theoretical physicist he was also
a great expositor and writer not many
physicists regularly published
articles in the journal nuclear physics
b and the physical review
as well as in the new york review of
books
for weinberg the writing of science both
research papers and popularizations
was a solitary undertaking but the
process of science the
exchange of ideas that was a source of
incomparable joy
i don't collaborate well mostly because
i like writing and whoever else
collaborates with me i always like to
write the paper
the um so why not just write it um
the uh but i love the sense of
collaboration
that we we talk a common language and
um when i talk to other physicists about
what they're doing about what i'm doing
we understand each other and um
i i love that
being part of a circle of fellow
uh workers i remember when i was in high
school i saw the movie the red shoes
and of course it's a gorgeous movie and
bowled over by the music and the dancing
but one of the things that
got me about the red shoes was the sense
that
there was the set designer and the
composer
and the choreographer and they were all
working together and they all knew
what each other were doing and they
spoke common language
and i i thought that that was wonderful
and
you feel a little bit like that in
physics especially when a theorist
talks to an experimentalist because we
have very different skills
but we're all interested in the same
questions
weinberg complemented his groundbreaking
capacities in fundamental science
with a deep immersion in history he was
always
careful to say that he was not an
historian but his insights about the
future were
thoroughly influenced by his
understanding of the past
and as he looked to the future he gave
us words of caution
and wisdom i gave a talk at the world
science festival the only other time
i've been here
a few years ago called the crisis of big
science
fearing that science had reached a point
where we really have to build these
enormous accelerators and uh
observatories in space we've
answered the questions that can be
answered with string and sealing wax in
lord rutherford's famous phrase and
society may be giving up on us we saw
the cancellation of a great project to
build
a large elementary particle accelerator
in the united states
incidentally it was in texas but um
i was for it before that site was chosen
the um uh and we we thought well
you know america which had been at the
forefront
of this kind of really fundamental
scientific research
was now surrendering that position
fortunately
uh physicists in europe picked up the
torch
and we've seen great discoveries made
at the large hadron collider in geneva
but it it's possible that it's coming to
an end
and that just
as in the scientific revolution
scientists
look back over the middle age back to
hellenistic greece
some 2000 years earlier
perhaps our descendants will look back
to the 20th century as a golden age
which
began to peter out in the 21st i
well as you can imagine i hope that's
not true
i and i don't know that it is true but i
fear it maybe
stephen weinberg developed some of the
most far-reaching
insights into the nature of reality
using some of the most
abstract techniques which experiment has
shown essential
to our mathematical articulation of
physical law
in this way weinberg paralleled the
journey taken a century ago
by albert einstein einstein often
described his quest
as seeking to understand the mind of the
old one
a quest for the workings of nature that
einstein referred to with what he
described
as a religious reverence stephen
weinberg
shared that reverence for the power and
beauty of mathematical explanation
but he also made clear that none of
these insights suggested to him
a higher power or an overarching purpose
to human life
a realization that for weinberg was a
source of freedom
and nobility well i think everything's
pointless
uh in the sense that there's no point
out there
to be discovered by the methods of
science
it's not it's not to say that we don't
create
points for our lives for many people
it's
it's their loved ones the
living a a life helping
people you love that's all the point
for that's needed for many people and
probably the
the main point for me
um and for some of us
there's a point in scientific discovery
and
other points but these are all
invented uh by humans
and um there's nothing out there
that supports them and it's better that
we not look for it
in a way we're freer in a way it's more
noble
and more admirable
to give
point to our lives ourselves rather than
to accept it from some external source
i could not agree more
everything we've learned from science
points toward life and
we human beings more particularly as
being
nothing but sophisticated biological
machinery composed
of the very particles and influenced by
the very forces described by the
mathematics
of the standard model and much as an
electron or a cork has no
point to its existence has no intrinsic
meaning or
purpose in its existence large
collections of such particles
like you and me we have no intrinsic
meaning
or purpose either now
that can sound bleak i even recall
hearing stephen weinberg on occasion
describing this outlook
as bleak but i'd suggest an alternative
perspective that i hold to be
utterly essential a perspective that
resonates well with weinberg's remark
that
it is more noble for us to find meaning
and purpose
on our own rather than accepting it from
an external source or
power how stunning
and how spectacular it is that we
biological machines governed by
physical law have the capacity to rise
above moment-to-moment survival and
invent
concepts including purpose and meaning
as well as
beauty and wonder and insight and
understanding and
and how fortunate we all are that one
such collection of particles
stephen weinberg and his brief moment on
the cosmological timeline
so profoundly deepened our grasp of
those concepts
allowing us all to stand on his
shoulders
and see that much farther
[Music]
[Music]
you